يوم الجمعه في مايتي سبورت مسجد برج
الدرايسه وكل ذلك حاتم رجل تخرج من جامعه
الخرطوم كليه البيطره واخذ ماجستير في في
في علم البيطره وكان من من موظفي شركه
شيكان سنين طويله جدا وكم مدير
مسؤول جسم او من المؤسسين او قد يكون واحد
حقيقه مؤسس لجسم تامر الحيوان في في في في
في في
الشركه
مدير مكتب شيكان في كوستي سنوات عديده
الكميه واعداد الناس اللي جوا يعني
الزملاء حاتم عماد كبيره جدا جدا من الناس
حاتم تقدم لوظيفه التنافس اللي هي بتم عبر
افريقيا كلها اللي هو مدير مكتب الكوميسي
في السودان وفاز بهذا الوظيفه لانه رجل
يتحدث اللغه الانجليزيه بطلاقه التامه
ورجل تعلم الاداره في شركه من السنين
الطويل والنجاحات الكبيره اللي حققها في
شركه شيكان همم بعد ذاك همم استمر مع في
مدير لمكتب
الكوميسي في ثلاث سنوات طويله وكان همم
باعتباره رجل يحمل جواز دبلوماسي بيقول له
اسف رجل بكل هذه المواصفات
نجب واحد من الكتاب يكتب ويقول الله حاتم
كان يعني ما عنديش ذريه
ان احنا ما فارقنا حاتم الحياه
يعني باعتبار ما يمكن يعني نقول ربينا
يعني على الاطلاق والله لم نسمع عن انه
حاتم من الايام تحدث او اخرج من لسانه
كلمتين
حاتم مربع تربيه بتاعه اسر كبيره
[موسيقى]
يعني
عبد الرحمن الله يرحمه ويغفر له واخته
وارحمه واغفر له ومقداد لبقي له في حياته
يعني من من من اسره يعني انتهت فيها 20
سنه والله رباهم تربيه والله نحن نحسده
نعم نعم
نحن حاجه
دخلت كليه الطب السنه الان وانا والله
العظيم قبليه بين 10 يوم الى اسبوعين
والله جيت
ابينها يعني
بدرجه عاليه جدا هو يرتكب جريمه تخلي زوج
ينتقم منه
يحددوها اما ما سالت ما سالت الاراضي
والقطايحين على الاطلاق ده كلام فارغ
واحنا ردينا عليهم في الميديا
ويطرزوا للاطلقه لشعريه ان يعتذر وقعت في
امريكا
في توصيل الرساله بالنسبه
[موسيقى]
واشرفنا على الجثث استلمناها من الشرطه
كنا موجودين احنا مع الشرطه لغايه ما خشنه
المشرحه احنا عندنا ثلاثه جسامي فقط
[موسيقى]
ما شاء الله استدعوه ومشوا عربي عربي
وعصير
للموقف الكبير